unione la vita fa lavoro ricapita
io per esempio mi occupo di proteggere
giganti ma facciamo un passo indietro
so che non ci conosciamo oggi ma so già
che abbiamo molte cose in comune tra cui
una su cui vorrei soffermarmi oggi
almeno una volta nella nostra vita
abbiamo guardato dal basso per citante
intorno a noi
siamo stati tutti bambini
e cercate di ricordarvi com'ero io mi
ricordo che mi sentivo così lontana da
sapere quello che sapevano gli adulti da
lassù ma allo stesso tempo dal basso
mi sentivo più vicino alla terra ha
l'odore dell'erba a seguire solo le
grilli ad alzare ogni singola pietà del
giardino per scoprire chi lo abitava
e così ogni giorno scoprivo vicine di
lombrichi e millepiedi porcellini terra
forbicine un giorno mi ricordo che
trovai una piccola cazzola è così
piccola io in comparazione era un
gigante ma lei ingenuo usciva dalla sua
fragile conchiglia e avrei potuto
spezzava in un secondo ma non lo feci
mi insegnarono che ogni essere vivente
piccolo grande esso sia merita rispetto
perché alla fine dei conti abbiamo tutti
nello stesso posto però sapete facile da
capire quando siamo piccoli vicini alla
terra e siamo quasi una cosa sola poi
però cresciamo e prendiamo le distanze
ci siamo noi e la natura due entità
distinte
solo cama non ha mai convinto questa
divisione infatti diventando biologa
della conservazione che chi si occupa di
studiare restaurare o proteggere
ecosistemi specv e l'estinzione fu come
prendere uno schiaffo in faccia quando
capì che quei piccoli essere che tanto
mi affascina qualora piccola come i
vertebrati non sono inutili ricordi
infanzia ma rappresentano più del 97 per
cento di tutte le specie animale nel
mondo e stanno scomparendo un ritmo
allarmante è dovuto all'azione umana
97 per cento a tanto è come se noi in
questo teatro siamo circa 400 persone
invece che essere circa 400 esseri umani
saremmo circa 388 coleotteri scarafaggi
lumache chiocciole rani api vespe
formiche e forse metà dell'unghia di uno
di voi potrebbe rappresentarci come
specie
anche se molte volte non notiamo questi
esseri sono ovunque intorno a noi si
stanno muovendo in questo momento sotto
il pavimento
alcuni forse sono entrate stanno
assistendo a questa presentazione
altri permettono la produzione di circa
tre quarti di tutte le culture
alimentare del mondo come insetti
impollinatori
oppure permettono aiuta nella
progettazione delle acqua il controllo
dei parassiti delle piante la formazione
del suolo e in generale tutti quei
servizi che sistemi naturali ci prestano
anche a noi e che se monetizzati
equivale a bra circa una fattura anno e
del doppio dell'intero pil mondiale che
noi non paghiamo ma
so che il beneficio che le altre specie
ci possa con cui condividiamo il mondo
ci possono dare importante agli occhi di
un adulto il beneficio monetario ma vi
dicono non ci farò mai capire realmente
chi siamo e cosa rischiamo di perdere e
come se
questa enorme diversità di specie di
geni con cui condividiamo il mondo fosse
un'altra complessa torre genga in cui
ognuno dei suoi pezzettini permette di
mantenere funzionanti quei sistemi che
prestano anche a noi adesso ha sempre
sopravvivere e ogni qual volta ti diamo
via uno di quei pezzetti quella terrà
sempre meno possibilità di poter
resistere ad eventuali perturbazioni
come le alterazioni climatiche fino al
suo crollo
è come se noi decidessimo di avere a
disposizione una micro gocce d'acqua
almeno da bere ogni giorno
e quando ci accorgiamo che il bicchiere
mezzo vuoto è troppo tardi
ecco ora pensate di essere i bambini del
nostro presidente
i vostri figli
fratelli sorelle
alunni nipoti e sapere che nasce the gli
affitti
già dall'inizio
meno gocce d'acqua disposizione
questa meravigliosa diversità della vita
con cui condividiamo il mondo non è un
interminabile dispensa perché non è
stata fatta per noi ma con noi
e noi siamo molto più dipendenti da
lordi quanto loro siano da noi
perché mi dispiace dirlo ma se noi come
specie scomparisse ma domani il pianeta
con gli dovrebbe esistere
e fondamentalmente questi piccoli
esserini ci ricordano quanto siamo
fragili se nella nostra apparente
grandezza ci dimentichiamo diamo per
scontato che ci permette di vivere
ma sapete mi piace pensare che per
ognuna di queste specie che sta
scomparendo al mondo esiste soltanto
una o più di una persona che deve
soltanto interessarsi alla storia e
cominciare a farne parte
e per questo oggi vi voglio portare
sulla linea dell'equatore e raccontarvi
la storia dei giganti della foresta
e voi ora vi chiederete ma chi sono sti
giganti
per chi ancora non l'abbia capito video
alcuni indizi allora vanno più veloci di
quello che normalmente pensate e se li
mettiamo contatto con la nostra mano
cercheranno di assaggiarli pure loro
centinaia di lentini
cosa potranno mai essere queste grandi
feste pericolose
e se fossero delle chiocciole giganti
sapete le chiocciole
nel loro quotidiano si svegliano e
contribuiscono a riciclo di nutrienti
alla formazione del suolo sono fonti di
cibo per molti animali come le lucciole
o come gli uccelli che a volte usano
l'eroe conchiglie come fonte di calcio
per produrre le uova
sono anche però uno dei gruppi animale
con il maggior numero di estensioni di
boot all'azione umana perché pensate
nonostante non siano così l'ente non
sono capaci di poter volare via
occorrere quando qualcuno altre al posto
dove vivono e quindi quando scompaiono
è come se fosse un campanello d'allarme
per quel luogo che ci fa capire che sta
diventando malato forse in modo
irreversibile
questa clausola
come altre decine di chiocciole e
lumache esiste soltanto in africa
centrale in due isole sulla linea
dell'equatore
l'era meravigliose isole di san tomè e
principe
cercate di catapultarvi la con
della foresta sentireste sicuramente
sempre il costante odore di pioggia
calda e poi i suoni di uccelli che
esistono soltanto la isolò pican schito
liga lignola seria e poi non solo il
calore dell'ambiente c'è anche il calore
che trasmettono le persone che vivono la
queste isole fino a pochi secoli fa non
sapevo nemmeno che esistessero e erano
quasi totalmente ricoperte da foresta
vergine poi però qualcuno alle scoprì e
come successo è successo in varie parti
del mondo non si rese conto del tesoro e
specie che esisteva la
cominciò alterarle con gravi squilibri
perle per le specie che la vedevano come
questa chiocciola che era molto
abbondante ma poi
comincia a scomparire
e quindi eccoci nella foresta tropicale
a cercare di capire dove ancora esisteva
questa chiocciola
però
capiamo subito che non era una
un'avventura facile ma con i miei
compagni non
cerchiamo comunque di andare avanti e
cerchiamo in alcune aree della frase
native in cui non avevano ancora
scoperto se c'erano e arrivammo in una
montagna su un picco di una montagna
fino una valle fino a che ci sentimmo un
po osservati
primariamente orno erano lì erano
davanti a noi invece che nascondersi
come fanno normalmente le chiocciole
dentro la conchiglia
uscirono quasi totalmente con i loro
occhietti quasi a scrutarci
non potete immaginare la gioia nel
vedere una specie a cui pensavamo
ansiosamente da mesi finalmente
realizzava anche a noi io dissi ok
attenzione dobbiamo fare buona
impressione perché probabilmente la
prima volta che vedono qualcuno della
nostra specie un essere umano
perché sapete
questa chiocciola così come altre specie
nel mondo no non è nata ieri questa
specie i fissi la milioni di anni la sua
storia è molto antica
e
a volte penso chissà cosa ha passato
durante tutto questo tempo nella foresta
cosa ha visto cosa ha sentito e anche se
nel nostro recente passato siamo
cresciute in posti diversi del mondo in
quel momento eravamo una davanti
all'altra
e cominciavamo a far parte della stessa
storia
però poi quella gioia su un po
trasformata in paura perché a parte me i
miei compagni di avventura che si
sarebbe occupato di questa specie che
sarebbe interessato
è solo una delle tante specie al mondo
che scompaiono senza che nessuno e
nemmeno se ne accorga
però poi dalle montagne cd scendevamo
per le comuni le comunita e succedeva
qualcosa di diverso ogni volta che
arrivavamo nelle comunità parlando con
le persone
loro ci chiedevano cosa sta succedendo
la nostra chiocciola
lavorando gli occhi speranzosi e degli
anziani
capimmo che loro ancora si ricordavano
al calcio la si sta distinguendo dalla
foresta ma non si è distinta dalla loro
memoria infatti da piccoli erano
abituati a raccoglierla dietro casa e
non sapevano nemmeno che esistesse solo
in quelle due isole del mondo quindi
capimmo che eravamo ancora in tempo per
poter fare qualcosa tutti insieme per
questa specie e per il posto dove vive
di quelle persone sono dipendenti la
foresta
poi però guardando i bambini la storia
era differente
i loro occhi erano indifferenti perché
la chiocciola la scomparsa così
rapidamente che loro sapevano nemmeno
cosa fosse
senza esperienza conosciuto ricordi
delle condizioni ambientali passate le
nuove generazioni non possono capire
quanto sia cambiato l'ambiente e quindi
generazione dopo generazione
alla progressiva degradazione
dell'ambiente segue una progressiva
inconsce accettazione del suo stato
alterato
diminuisce sempre di più il grado di
connessione con con la natura il legame
e il ricordo con essa fino addirittura a
poter sfociare nella paura per le altre
forme di vita prendendo ancora più grave
a questo degrado ambientale
ma quello che succede a san tomè e
principe non succede solo l'acqua
succede in ogni posto del mondo succede
anche qua
non so se vi ricordate
nelle notti d'estate
quelle luci nell'oscurità
beh ci siamo accorti che varie specie di
lucciole in tutto il mondo stanno
scomparendo
se gli altri esseri viventi
permettono che noi continuiamo esistere
e le loro storie formano i nostri
ricordi allora quando loro si estinguono
si estingua anche una parte di noi
ea volte gridiamo
salviamo il pianeta salviamo la natura è
giusto ma non ci stiamo automaticamente
escludendo la questione lui
alessandra tura non siamo così diversi
non siamo così
indipendenti siamo molto più vicini e
dipendenti di quello che pensiamo e se
vogliamo salvare noi stessi dobbiamo
accorge scegli chi ci sta intorno
perché senza natura non possiamo
esistere se noi stessi siamo parte di
lei
ma quindi perché da essi tanto da fare
per una chiocciola
io mi rifiuto che ciò che amo scompaia e
ciò che amano fa parte solo di me ma fa
parte anche di voi di tutti noi che
viviamo in questo stesso posto
e voi vi chiederete è ok ma quindi io
cosa devo fare ora
sapete il modo in cui guardiamo il mondo
i robot stiamo ai bambini
insegniamo le cose è il modo in cui loro
impareranno a osservarlo a capirlo ad
amarlo infine a rispettarlo così come
anche noi adulti a volte dovremmo
ricordarci di abbassarci come quando
eravamo bambini e guardare il mondo da
un'altra prospettiva
vedere qualcuno di diverso e non avere
timore o indifferenza trasformale in
curiosita cercare di capire la sua
storia e come il suo senso di esistere
se anche legato al nostro
nelle isole di san tomè e principe le
persone hanno cominciato a far parte
della storia di questa specie hanno
imparato alla grandezza che esiste nei
più piccoli i legami che esistono fra le
varie specie e noi è cominciato a fare
qualcosa per la sua salvaguardia
ma non vi sto dicendo che per fare
qualcosa dovete andare fino sulla linea
dell'equatore
basta soltanto fermarsi
cercare di capire cosa importante
guardare fuori dalla finestra
il lungo della strada c'è sempre una
pezza che ha bisogno di aiuto una specie
di coloro che sta scomparendo lo
sapevamo nemmeno oppure semplicemente
una lumaca da osservare
e il modo in cui noi ci accorgiamo di
loro in un solo del panda e della tigre
bianca
ci fa capire quanto sia fondamentale
comprendere come anche noi facciamo
parte di quella stessa complessa ma
fragile torre genga e del modo in cui
trasferiamo questo amore ai bambini e
raccontiamo le loro storie che loro
cresceranno
rendendosi conto delle nostre origini
comuni e sapendosi prendere cura della
nostra casa
perché alla fine noi siamo gitanti quale
ci prendiamo cura anche dei più piccoli
e noi adulti agli occhi dei bambini
siamo sempre giganti per questo voi che
tipo di giganti volete essere
grazie
[Applauso]